За 30 років незалежності в Україні фактично так і не сформувався
середній клас. Принаймні це випливає з актуального соцдослідження,
проведеного Держстатом. У його межах було опитано майже 8 тисяч домогосподарств.
І лише один відсоток респондентів віднесли себе до середнього класу.
32 відсотки не вважають себе ані середнім класом, ані бідними.
І аж 67 відсотків назвали себе бідними.
Чи справді в Україні немає середнього класу?
Фінансист Сергій Фурса пояснює таку статистику особливостями
українського менталітету. Мовляв, українці звикли бідкатися і, навіть будучи
середнім класом, схильні вважати, що вони занадто бідні.
Один відсоток - ми розуміємо, що це не може бути правдою.
Ми зараз на вулицях Києва, наповненого автотранспортом,
магазини наповнені людьми. Кожного року нерухомість розкуповується
шаленими темпами. Це не ознака, що в нас лише один відсоток середнього класу.
Туристи вивозять з України кожного року 4 мільярди доларів.
Це також не ознака одного відсотка середнього класу.
Тому в нас набагато більше середнього класу, ніж люди говорять.
В нас дійсно досі є проблема нерівності, є спеціальні коефіцієнти,
які виводить Світовий банк. В нас більша нерівність, ніж є у Європі,
і менша, ніж у Латинській Америці. Але в нас точно немає 70 відсотків бідних людей.
У Європі середній клас почав формуватися ще в Середньовіччі.
Приміром, у Німеччині жителі міст - так звані "бюргери" -  не були ані кріпаками,
ані серед панівних класів. Вони були так би мовити "звичайними" громадянами,
які серед іншого мали обов'язок захищати свої міста у разі нападу.
По суті, вони і сформували те, що в сучасній Європі
називають середнім класом.
Він допоміг стимулювати економічне зростання та стабілізувати демократію -
адже ці верстви населення завжди прагнули захистити своє становище у суспільстві.
Вони стійкі до змін, хоча й дуже неоднорідні.
Чіткого визначення, хто належить до середнього класу,
зокрема, в Україні немає.
Деякі економісти визначають середній клас відповідно до медіанного рівня доходів,
який ділить населення на дві рівні групи: половина з доходом вище цього показника
та половина з доходом нижче. І ця сума відрізняється від "середнього доходу".
Приміром, минулого року медіанний дохід на душу населення у Німеччині
становив 43 200 євро на рік.
Уряд ФРН вважає всіх, хто отримує від 60 до 200 відсотків цього доходу, середнім класом.
А як щодо інших країн?
Середній дохід в Індії, приміром, становить 1900 євро на рік.
Тоді як у Демократичній Республіці Конго - лише 470 євро.
Без контексту ці цифри, втім, не є ознакою соціального класу.
На думку багатьох економістів, більш показовою є купівельна спроможність населення.
Якщо ви можете дозволити собі холодильник, пральну машину, мотоцикл
або звичайну відпустку, то ви належите до середнього класу.
У Києві, наприклад, усе дорожче, ніж в Івано-Франківську.
Тож не потрібно людині, щоб відчувати той самий рівень життя, заробляти стільки ж
в Івано-Франківську, скільки він мав би заробляти в Києві.
Тому це має бути якесь комплексне вимірювання,
яке передбачає дуже багато факторів, включаючи перш за все якість життя.
Не вартість життя в цифрах, а якість життя в якихось коефіцієнтах.
Тож не дивно, що, за  результатами соцопитування Держстату,
67 відсотків  опитаних українців назвали себе бідними і при цьому
понад 60 відсотків респондентів вважають свої доходи минулого року достатніми.
Скільки ж, на думку українців, треба заробляти, щоб бути середнім класом в Україні?
За даними соцопитування Держстату, понад 7 відсотків респондентів вважають,
що необхідно мати від 14 до 16 тисяч гривень на місяць.
Майже 14 відсотків - що від 18 до 20 тисяч.
І переважна більшість опитаних українців понад - 70 відсотків - вважатимуть
себе середнім класом, якщо зароблятимуть щомісячно понад 22 тисяч гривень.
У червні 2021 року середня номінальна зарплата в Україні,
заданими Держстату, становила майже 14 з половиною тисяч гривень.
Це приблизно 530 доларів.
Також стверджується, що заостанні 12 місяців номінальна зарплата
зросла на23 з половиною відсотки.
Ареальна середня зарплата, тобто це та кількість товарів і послуг,
яку ви можете придбати за свою номінальну зарплату залежно від рівня цін і податків -
на13 відсотків. При цьому варто також враховувати, що
за даними парламентського комітету з соцполітики,
понад чверть економічно активного населення України
отримує тіньові доходи, що перевищують 20 мільярдів гривень.
Важливим фактором для формування середнього класу
є і соціальна захищеність населення, гарантована державою.
Німці більш соціально захищені. Те, що є в Європі
і чого нема в Україні чи Сполучених Штатах, це впевненість, що з тобою буде,
коли ти втратиш роботу. Бо насправді та сама ситуація у США.
Ви чудово себе почуваєте, доки у вас є робота.
Як тільки ви цю роботу втрачаєте, ви відразу переходите в іншу категорію.
Особливо це стосується країн, що розвиваються, де хвороба або втрата роботи
можуть призвести до раптового переходу за межу бідності.
Так до спалаху коронавірусу середній клас швидко збільшувався
в Азіатсько-Тихоокеанському регіоні.
Але пандемія COVID-19 завадила цьому зростанню.
До того, як це сталося, Світовий банк визначив, що у світі
майже один мільярд 380 мільйонів жителів
представляють середній клас. Нині ж цей показник впав на 60 мільйонів.